Remember that this is a program mostly funded
by memberships.
Membership sort of quick, easy, cheap and
come with the daily bonus show an extra show
just for our members.
Grab a membership in under a minute or take
longer.
I mean, listen, if you want to spend five
minutes on it, by all means, but you only
need about 45 seconds at join Pacman dot com.
It is time for hatriot mail.
Quick reminder.
What is hatriot mail anyway?
Because we don't care about liberal kux so
much that we spend our time writing to them.
Teary eyed man written by patriots who hate
David Pakman because of America and because
freedom.
Yeah.
So Hatriot Mail is I get a lot of hate mail
and some of it is interpretively read by a
professional voiceover artist.
There is a lot of meat and really ugly stuff
in this week's Hatriot Mail.
Let's take a listen.
David Pakman hating on guns.
Ho.
Jewish.
Confirmed.
Yep.
Predictable, David.
I could only get through a moment of your
socialist drivel.
Weird because David doesn't really look Jewish.
I am.
Oh.
But listen to him for a second.
And you know, David, how do you explain Jewish
people's success yet?
Don't look.
Jewish continues to be an interesting one
that we've talked about that.
And in fact, there's there's actually a lot
of interesting sociological stuff about this
idea of looking Jewish or looking this, that
or the other thing.
Let's not get into that, because that gets
pretty ugly.
But still, with the socialist stuff at this
point, it's a very interesting thing.
I think I get as much criticism from the audience,
from people who attack me wrongly for being
a socialist or a communist, as I do from people
who are mad that I'm not a socialist or a
communist.
It's a very interesting thing.
As many of you know, I'm a social Democrat
in the northern European tradition.
This is a form of capitalism as well regulated
capitalism, using redistributive mechanisms
to ensure that no one standard of living is
is unnecessarily low.
And there are people on the right who don't
care and insist that I am a socialist or a
communist.
And then there are people on the left who
are mad that I'm not actually a socialist
or a communist.
You can't please everybody.
And lately it seems like you almost can't
please anybody.
But what you can do to fight hatriot schism
in your community is to use the coupon code
Hatriot 40.
When you sign up for a membership, you go
to join Pacman dot com.
You will be presented with a coupon code field.
You type in hatriot 40 HHC ROTC for zero and
you'll save 40 percent.